- Ann Reardon of How to Cook That
points out that lots of people
would probably hurt themselves
because of stress viral cooking videos.
And she asked the question.
- Could they see the
sue the platform owner?
- This is a great question,
and one of the few times
when I can confidently say
that there is an answer, at
least in the United States.
There's reasons why
YouTube won't be liable
for people posting really stupid content.
One is the terms of service,
you know that contract
that you didn't read when
you signed up for YouTube,
that basically absolves
YouTube of all liability
related to the videos.
And the second reason is
that infamous section 230
of the Communications Decency Act,
which provides some protection
for website operators
and the platforms.
Specifically section
230 prevents a website
or a platform like YouTube or anyone else
from having liability for
content posted by somebody else.
And that's probably a good
thing because if YouTube
was responsible for every
stupid thing that a user posted,
well, there probably wouldn't
be too many users on YouTube.
So no YouTube isn't
liable, but theoretically
those individual users could be,
so maybe we'll see them in court.